da keine perle rauskriegen 80 auf
gerader außen fall runter oh mein gott
bin ich dumm
hey leute jetzt willkommen zu einer
weiteren folge von scheiben heute extra
brötchen für mich am frühen
sonntagmorgen gibt nichts mehr gibt
nichts mehr nein
wie dumm wer gerade eine pause gab es
die große brauche ich ja doch nicht
gegessen wie du über das denn wieso
brauchst du rote ich freue mich mehr für
eine quest aber ich kann ja aus dem
weizen machen aber trotzdem es ist halt
nein nein nein
unproduktiver der hier wieder am werk
also leute was wir sagen wollten wir
machen pause bis zum sechzehnten ca
sommer im hause geht erst im dezember
wieder los und weil ich im urlaub bin
und ich somit ganz einfach dass ich
meine form auch meine farm meine form
aber ich brauche auch gar keine
kakaobohnen mehr fällt mir ein ich hab
schon jetzt 26 glaube ich wir brauchen
noch eine menge weit sind einfach für
die ganzen kekse du musst auch nach
pflanzen dort habe ich hast du nicht
gemacht ich habe gemacht ihr shop
vielleicht nicht weiß nicht wir machen
sommerpause bis zum 16.8 ca und danach
geht es normal weiter wie vorher dann
auch das ist auch immer du voll mit dem
pausen und warum
ja ich bin jetzt urlaub bis 16 8 und
danach habe ich noch drei wochen ferien
und da werden wir dann richtig
durchziehen mega projekt durchziehen und
so weiter und so fort da wird dann alles
kommen egal also nicht dass ich da
wundert bei mir ich ziellos bei mir sind
da also das ist ja gerade video hier auf
meinem kanals ihnen kann ich das mal
ganz gut sagen bei mir sind da videos
geplant für die zeit immer so ein paar
das sie dann so ein bisschen
unterhaltung noch ab zwischendurch
während der sommerpause aber danach geht
es dann halt nochmal weiteren da geht
sondern produktiver weiter hier bleibt
also weiter
wir müssen in eine spitzhacke touch oder
so verzaubern
ach genau ich weiß ja noch jetzt ins
nacht konnten richtig geilen plan hast
du noch bisschen gras haben wir hier
ich würde mir graf gibt sich dann wird
hier ein traum wahr und ich nicht gras
wegnehmen
doch obwohl ja ist spielplans genau
wieso ich brauche noch klar ist das
heißt wir brauchen sind kannst du ganz
kurz bisschen dienstes mitnehmen zum
tauschen klinsmann kriegen den sand her
austauschen
da gab's so irgendwie ist alles tauschen
ihr habt dann glaube ich eine variante
für sand ein skater ist okay
interessante knochen aber nein kein
skelett ist natürlich immer schön dass
herr bin gerne und sie wird auch keine
skelette kaum dip und meine lieben nicht
leben
keystone was ihr alles noch brauch gibt
es die möglichkeit dass man sand bekommt
andere länder mit triple endermann keine
perle rauskriegen gerade 38 gerade aus
dem fall runter oh mein gott bin ich
dumm alter habe mich dort gekratzt aber
das denn dabei da einfach mal quattro
endermann jetzt casting ich habe 49
steinreiche natürlich
sie sind aber gleichzeitig so warte ich
muss dir einfach hier alle auf den
gegnern die musst du jetzt einsammeln
random entfalle breit mache ich jetzt
sofort trade wir brauchen kakteen wo
kriegen wir den katheter wie man kann
sich athen in die kräfte der eben
wichtig machen ja ganzen das ist es ist
toll meine ganzen weile ganzen alten
kaputten prügeln hier so was braucht man
noch klar versand helium brauchen sorg
dich nicht irgendwo hatte ich irgendwann
verzauberung tisch hier von euch da
winslet ist unbedingt man kann zwei
spitzhacken reinpacken und dann kann man
da auswählen was man haben will
behutsamkeit haltbarkeit erwartest du
das auch gar nicht zaubern eigentlich
doch ich darf ich bin da schon etwas
weiter nee nee was heißt denn dirk
potthoff deutsch am kite okay gut aber
ich würde am liebsten das nicht auf
seine kappe spitzhacke machen sondern am
liebsten auf reisen oder so spargelstadt
örtlicher rüstung holen für gold nugget
die musikkultur
wir können uns auch mit 48 weizen eine
kuh holen was eine dicke nach einfach
gras machen uns beide tiere bei graz
montieren oder doch wo sonst ihre
spawnen nicht mehr so haben wir waren
die kommentare geschrieben habe
ernsthaft dass er google aber ich weiß
nicht ob das wirklich stimmt auf jeden
fall goldmann goldnuggets ich finde
seine entsteht meist wie kommt man an
goldmans
willst du was genau hinter fast
mitbringen zum zombie flash bories und
patrice evra aus ich brauch 32
verrottete fleisch nicht runter kommt
das fleisch von dem du homo warum ich
schlage man weiß ja dass der weizen
wächst ja immerhin also wie gesagt nur
einen scheiß gestern haben wir eine
weitere quest geschafft du deinen job
wirtschaft ja aber als 1000 zweiten
plätzen und es wird auch benutzern auch
bei dir die quest zu schaffen weil es
gibt es sehr cooles sein
ich brauche auf jeden fall zombie flash
cookies islam braucht ein 30 26 stücken
möchte doch nur die klasse 6d sonst nein
damals gar nicht stoppen hier rund 6 500
prozent
250 fahrzeugen gesammelt ich hab noch
560 ms points kategorisch kaputter dass
wer weiß was ist eigentlich die
mitbringen sollte es jedoch die ich mir
für die küste da ich habe eine gute idee
und zwar lief erst für die 15 kleinen
sollen eine terrasse machen und zwar
genau nach dem haus von anderen menschen
ich werde voll stark für eine
wasserrutsche immer wieder müssen nicht
bei diesen ganzen weg laufen
dann bauen wir uns ganz hoch und dann
machen wir fassen was allerdings
herunter diese sind die ganzen ändern
männer hier hätten nicht sterben aber ob
das auch noch eins das heißt ich habe 6
ich brauche aber 32 und vorreiter feiern
ohne die ganzen sachen aber der wand und
versand brauche ich kakteen und ich
weiter an
wie kommt's weißt du dich an kakteen
rankomme sonnig
elf spiele können fertig die kammer
konzentriert zumindest passiert dir nix
trotzdem wäre ja aber die leute bei mir
den doch ach nee das mit dem chat
angezeigte stürzen stimmt er trotzdem
ist tummeln sich keine mir gibt egal was
also nicht gegeben ist ich brauche
kakteen aber wie komme ich an kakteen
trauercafé erst mal überlaufen
was du trittst du musst du ganz ehrlich
bist ein monkey sich fritz walter kummer
ich machen skelette quasi gerade abgeht
nein der fälle das gut
rotten flesh der fritz der kann auch
prügeln heutigen skelett gekämpft da
kommt er tritt und schlägt das skelett
runter als ob doch ist aufgestanden
übergang und das runter geschlagen warte
ich noch mal kurz nein du bist wer du
brauchst du auch wusste ich mich richtig
junge mann ich brauche vor allem die
zombies sind anders ja und dann um zu
testen weil da war es auch sagen können
sie gar nicht raus so das ritz nur der
macht mit dem super jedoch wenn er an
gestern erklärte team gewalt eventuell
das bensheim
rst
glasauge hey du musst unbedingt einbauen
können wir was richtig gutes machen ich
weiß ja auch für dich zeigt sie dann
geballt
bestes mädchen steht jetzt ich habe die
sachen glaube ich gut gespielt elite
gesetz sieht hier große wahl ist sense
lvmh wieder einstand
ein sand und ein kaktus und ein kaktus
das heißt unendlich fakt ist aber das
ist gut weil katte spamming tauschen wo
erhält welchen worten du erledigt dafür
aber irgendwie macht so also wir haben
jetzt hier einen santjer glasauge also
tauschte machen jetzt als eines anfalls
ein kaktus versand dann die kakteen die
wir drauf kriegen natürlich im sand und
haben damit unendlich sand und danach
noch mccain drauf und haben auch bei
seinen noch manches glas noch glas
richtig glück super kommen fragen
gesamten das kann man verbrennungen
können
unser feld weiter feuer
ja da einfach so habe ich zwei mini um
scherben monster familie im steinbruch
und was verboten beste fahrer aller
zeiten ist es hier
sonar schön nächster job fünf brot
könnten wir noch brauchen
das ist noch zu weit kaktus haben wir
bald ihr karotten haben die nicht bei
mir auch nicht pumpkins blumen könnt ihr
brauchen also apple hast du ja apple sie
haben in die apps haben
das heißt zehn blumen und fünf rosenbaum
hier noch die ganzen job in den sachen
nicht gesammelt
aber jobs ist eigentlich egal ob es
richtig dass wir da wochen noch sechs
blumen und noch drei hosen und für all
das braucht nicht noch nie
hmm
komm schon mit der skelette alte die
sind alle tot
diese sind alle montag geburtstag aber
alle monster hast du hast noch ein
boxring knochen
mehr hab ich nicht kommen schon ein
ich habe sagte er seinen hass aber ich
hab's schnee blöcke weiß nicht was mit
wie soll aber ich hab sie ok chef
zuckerrohr könne auch nicht machen ohne
dass blues holten mit charlotte wird
nein deswegen damit dann da da da dam
skelette die kripo die letzten
betonte fritz ist auch ins gerät oder
einzelne 21 du meinst du fritz könnte
eventuell unseren knochen abdrücken nach
fritz kommt stehe unter vorm regen
oben hat man wirklich von ihnen geben
die fresse bekommen sport
gaggenau wochenende männer der hat mich
ziemlich ja weil ich das hier erfüllen
muss man aber da müssen wir zur zeit
warten bis die kakteen wachsen
allerdings sind jetzt auch schon der 15
minuten um das hat was zu essen und
stelle mich dann zum spot macht mein
kleiner
o
was los in der metal folgt mich
irgendwie ändern verfolgt mich aber
kommen draußen im regen
sie haben wie das duftet rostock durch
wertvoll sind und trampel so rum rennen
sie zählen so freunde das war's dann mit
dieser folge wenn es euch gefallen hatte
sich gern eine bewertung abgeben
weiterhin wenn irgendwelche tipps
anbieter eventuell die jobs schneller
erfüllen können oder sonst welche sachen
wie zum beispiel das mit dem gras oder
sowas dann könnt ihr uns das wie immer
einfach in die kommentare schreiben
die rolle und ich sagen jetzt es bis zum
16.8 ca und dann geht's also eric
projekt directly wald sondern auch mit
etwa produziert bzw
beim berlin kommen auch ganz normal
videos aber ich bin halt nicht da bin
ich weiter aufnehmen
deswegen also wenn er keine kommentare
beantworten besten mods ganz groß rum
warum warum willst du macht videos bist
du tot bist du tot
na gut dann bald wartet erwarte ich kann
nicht eine so lange zeit ohne einen
letzten schlag ergehen lassen das wäre
jetzt echt zu viel gewesen
nein ich habe ganz schnell einen gmt pci
hd kontrast aber ich hab' kontrastiert
geströmt du hast auch ein versuch
okay das geschafft
den fall zufrieden wenn wir die daten
leute beginnen demnächst wieder ciao
auch okay so